e
e e
if you uh stand and join me in the
Pledge of
Allegiance thank you raron for coming
today um we're we're still waiting on a
couple of answers to a couple questions
um but um I'd like to um go right to the
Amendments that have been drafted um in
in in the committee testimony we heard
that um there has been a lot of issues
with leases um with state agencies and
political subdivisions so we wanted to
create um a statute that kind of brings
it um it brings fairness into it by um
using uh fair market rates in uh lease
renewals so I did draft an amendment um
specifying that um and we received um
another amendment from I'm sorry your
name would you like to come up to the
table and um just explain what you did
here in this amendment
thank you madam chair uh members of the
committee my name is Kate Horan I
represent the New Hampshire Association
of counties so uh representative Lon had
asked us to work on defining what fair
market value was um so we played around
with that a little bit and what we
determined is so buildings are appraised
every 5 years um but you could get an
appraisal at any time if you know the
county or the state wanted to pay for it
to get a more upto-date
number um and so what we did was so you
take that divide it by the square
footage of the building and then take
out any depreciation that the building
has so like if the building doesn't have
working electricity and the state's
going to come in and they're going to
have to do an upgrade so that the
building works that number would be
counted for in the determination of fair
market value um and then we just added
in any additional expenses included but
not limited to utilities custodial
Services things like that should be
negotiated separately um we didn't want
to make it a very Define list because uh
I think I pointed out like 50 years ago
no one needed you know fiber optic lines
and things like that you know who in
another 50 years everyone may need a
drone landing pad or something like that
they're building um but um that's kind
of what we did and as I said um to the
chairwoman you know no pride of
authorship here we just wanted to try
and put something in front of you for
you guys to work
with go
ahead thank you for taking my question
Kate so uh kind of uh to go back to the
question about uh depreciation that we
were talking about before the meeting uh
is that the average loss over time or
what what are we talking about when
we're looking at that depreciation um I
think that's uh counties do depreciation
on things all the time
um and it's it's usually at that point
so you know a building or a piece of
land may be worth because of where it's
located a whole bunch more but at that
moment in time if it doesn't have you
know functioning electrical or water
sewer or something like that then we
wanted we were trying to be fair to make
it account for any uh deficiencies that
the building may have okay thank
you um thank you for testifying today um
market value for a property can vary
dramatically from an appraised value and
sometimes they're not even close right
um the goal is have an apprais value
that approximates market value but it
doesn't always work that way yeah and I
will say so that there's no nothing in
this language requires them to use this
so if they want to negotiate a different
rate I think in that line before that
unless agreed to upon a different rate
this is just an option if you wanted to
negotiate by fair market value yeah I I
think it's better to just stick with the
phrase fair market value and not bring
in appraised value because you can get
off track like in our town in Milford uh
the the average market value uh the
appraised value is
67% of sure market value uh which which
is very low sure and um
you know you you could be way off and
that that's kind of a typical thing when
the prices of properties are changing
like they've been skyrocketing lately
yeah you know a ratio of 67% is not out
of line it used to not be that way you
know things didn't change that much and
it would be pretty close 90% or or
something um yeah we were just trying to
find something that would work across
all 10 counties uh because obviously you
know uh property and cost is very
different than Rockingham is very
different from chesher so but honestly
if you guys don't want to use this and
leave it at fair market value I think
we're comfortable with that can can can
the other thing is that um market value
for a lease of a of a uh a unit can be
quite different than the value of the
building sure uh you can um lease a unit
for $1,000 doll uh and by looking at the
value of the building it may it might be
$500 worth out $4,000 you know it could
be way off from what the market value of
leasing that space is right um I did
hear back from Mr farlin as well he does
not know what that chart says on the
gross item line he apologizes okay okay
okay so rep dargy
um are you saying that um in the red
there we would take out um the first
part of that first sentence and just put
additional expenses including but not
limited utilities custodial Services
Insurance exactly I I would delete that
first sentence Al together yeah the
first red
sentence and that kind of matches up
with um the letter that we received from
Mr furland and he he has this list of uh
categories related to um a particular
lease that they did and the he details
the individual things maintenance
Insurance utilities C
custodial Etc right right yeah I would
have to agree with you there yeah thank
you okayy thank
you rep Aaron um would you like to come
up to the stand um
in you've heard what we discussed and
I'm just wondering if if that would help
with um your constituent and his
concerns if we were to amend the bill
language okay I'm I'm not sure I know
what additional amendment has been
suggested yeah and it's uh with the
red so we would delete um that first
sentence in
red
mhm yeah I mean if if this is uh amable
to
uh U Mr furland and I imagine um Miss
Horgan then I'm fine with it to make
whatever
change thank you um there's a a
difference between the two lists um the
the actual um 0825 Amendment um in line
three three uh talks about space owned
by a political subdivision mhm so uh
that limits uh this change to just uh
things owned by a political subdivision
like a county and it's not
um a independently owned piece of
property um in the the one that's
described as cost approach it could just
be any lease and it doesn't have to be
owned by a thing of the town so I of the
state so I like the the the phrase owned
by a political
subdivision to be in there yeah uh what
I'm going to do is go down to OS and
work off my Amendment just adding that
last sentence in red and of course
changing um the RSA number that you
found um and um where it says custodial
Services Etc um I would like to take off
the the ETC and just put insurance and
maintenance
I I want to disagree with that going
back to representative or not
representative sorry uh Kate Horgan's
testimony uh and the fact that we don't
necessarily know what some of these new
expenses may be uh for instance uh one
of one of the examples was
Communications uh we didn't need uh
internet service uh 50 years ago uh
being delivered to the counties but we
do now so it is something where we may
want to uh kind of give a little bit of
leeway on that one we have the wording
not limited to
yes okay yeah you could just take out
the ETC I think that would cover it
could say additional expenses including
but not limited to utilities and
custodial at services period okay um no
no reason to put insurance and
maintenance in there no because you're
you've got the phrase including but not
limited to so all right I don't know if
you really if you need to like list them
all what makes sense all
right good good oh yes R dargie um I
have a question do we want to consider
making this uh going both ways right now
uh it only talks about space owned by a
political subdivision right being leased
by the state uh what about making it
space owned by the state and leas to a
political subdivision right how about I
think thought of that too so
um do we add the word
between any renewal between any renewal
of a lease for land buildings or space
between a political subdivision or a
state
agency shall be renewed at a fair market
rate did you repeat that again I did um
any renewal of lease for land buildings
or
space between a political subdivision
and a state agency and a state
agency that makes
sense so is there is there any case
where property would be owned by the
state but not by an agency or is it
always is it always owned by an
agency yeah I don't
know would that cover a yeah if if we
just said State I think that would also
include the state agencies so I think
that if we just leave it at state that
would be
good in the state of New Hampshire okay
and so so we don't need this reference
to the RSA if we were getting rid of the
phrase state agency
right
okay
so the amendment would read any renewal
of a lease for land buildings or space
between a political
subdivision and the State of New
Hampshire shall be renewed at a fair
market rate unless otherwise agreed upon
by the
lessor additional expenses including but
not limited to
utilities and custodial Services shall
be negotiated
separately that does it sounds good to
me that's good yeah sounds great all
agree in it yeah okay I'll go draft that
at OS okay right now awesome and I will
close the public um the sub committee
meeting on HB 694 thank you so much for
your working on this we really
appreciate it thank you for being here
today
either of you involved in voting
tomorrow
no yeah that that's that's very
strange that that would be the one
committee that you would think would
absolutely not be meeting tomorrow
exactly but
I
e
e for